what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the Marvel movie
timeline or our series of videos about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe timeline
and what I do for those of you guys who
are new to this is I basically go
through and I give you all the
background stuff I fill in the blanks
between what's going on in the movies
and how it is that agents of shield and
agent Carter and all the movies tie-in
together how it creates this great big
huge seamless universe that's a really
self-contained it's really cool because
Marvel has done a lot of work and making
sure the Marvel Cinematic Universe
really stays in line with their end goal
of whatever that end goal happens to be
so what we're gonna do in this video is
we're going to start with the 1940s now
for those of you guys who didn't see our
previous video where we had talked about
1930s some highlights here as we had
talked about how Tony Stark I'm sorry
Howard Stark had gone on to basically
launch Stark Industries how Abraham
Erskine the man who invented the Super
Soldier Serum and would later inject
that in Steve Rogers
to make in Captain America how prior to
this he was trying to escape Germany as
a nuremberg laws are being imposed and
he was captured by Nazis and then taken
back to the fortress of Johann Schmidt
who would later become the Red Skull
these are the kind of things we had
talked about in this video and so what
we do here is we pick up in the early
1940s and with around 1940 or so we find
that Howard Stark is basically
demonstrating to the US military how it
is a vibranium works this is the first
time we see vibranium in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now this seems to be
demonstrated for the purposes of
military applications but the fact
remains that this sparks an interest in
chester phillips who is played by tommy
lee jones and i Captain America the
First Avenger and as a result he's
basically caught the eye of Howard Stark
the two of them are sort of beginning to
work together but not as far as we will
see and I guess later on and this in
this video now what we do from here is
we jump to Johann Schmidt who has
already been injected with the Super
Soldier Serum at the hands of Abraham
Erskine now Marvel doesn't really give
us the actual injection of the Super
Soldier Serum they pretty much just jump
to Abraham Erskine being captured and
then Red Skull being injected with the
serum that's pretty much how this works
here there's really no middle ground
there and so as a result Red Skull it's
basically taking taken on his form the I
guess Johann Schmidt has become the Red
Skull and so as a result Abraham Erskine
still kind of kept confined to the
castle of Johann Schmidt but what we
learn is that Peggy Carter arrives and
Peggy Carter actually rescues Abraham
Erskine now Peggy Carter was
masquerading as a maid named Eva and the
whole idea here was for her to get in
rescue Abraham Erskine and then have him
join the strategic science reserve which
he does she when he's rescued he's
actually taken onto a plane with Howard
Stark and he's basically given the
opportunity to join the Allied forces
enough from here we jump to 1941 and one
of the more prominent dates here is that
in December 7th that the United States
enters World War two but what happens is
this very close I guess is very quick
timeline in 1941
almost immediately after we join into
into World War two we find that at the
same time that um I guess that Steve
Rogers is for the most part rejected
from joining the United States Army this
is what we had seen in the the beginning
of Captain America the First Avenger at
the same time around the same time we
find that Abraham Erskine basically
rejects a series of candidates that are
supposed to be used for the Super
Soldier Serum by by Chester Phillips now
again Chester Phillips who is played by
Tommy Lee Jones has selected these
candidates for their physical
capabilities because of they were
injected with the Super Soldier Serum
their physical capabilities would be
enhanced but as we know Abraham Erskine
wanted to be very very selective about
who it was that got the Super Soldier
Serum because all it does is magnify
what's on the inside it gives them
I guess enhanced strength and speed and
so on but it takes us on the inside and
it brings it on the outside which is the
reason why Johann Schmidt became the Red
Skull he was basically a reflection of
the evil within now for here we jumped
in 1942 in 1942 is again when we start
to pick up with Captain America the
First Avenger this is when we find
Johann Schmidt finding the tesseract
within the confines of a monastery this
is when he actually takes a tesseract if
you remember and he refers to it as the
the jewel of Odin's treasure room now
the other thing that happens in 1942 and
this touch is actually on agents of
shield and agent Carter is that Werner
Reince tat or as we know him Daniel
Whitehall finds the Kree corpse that we
would later see in an agents of shield
now we don't exactly know how it was or
what it was it led him to this all we
know is it's somewhere along the line he
was tasked with
finding different kinds of artifacts
some sort of supernatural artifacts
bye-bye most likely Red Skull as Daniel
Whitehall was a member of Hydra and this
ultimately led him to finding the Kree
corpse now in 1943 this is when we see
Abraham Erskine and Steve Rogers meeting
for the very first time this is when
Abraham Erskine basically offers Steve
Rogers the chance to demonstrate his
worth to prove that he could really be a
valuable soldier on the battlefield and
so this is when we see Steve Rogers
starting to Train we see him
demonstrating to Abraham Erskine that
he's capable of being Captain America
and then of course we see him injected
with the Super Soldier Serum stepping
into the role of Captain America but we
also see the death of Abraham Erskine
now in 1945 or I guess between 1943 and
1945 this is what we see pretty much
everything happening in in Captain
America the First Avenger this is what
we see the entire movie playing out now
in 1945 proper we of course see the
Steve Rogers is presumably dead he
fights the Red Skull and as a result
Steve Rogers simply vanishes and a lot
of people consider to him to be dead but
of course we know that he was frozen and
eventually thought out when his body was
discovered at the same time in 1945 this
is when Daniel Whitehall finds the
obelisk now we don't know how he found
the obelisk we have no earthly clue
where he located it at why he got it or
any of that stuff we simply just know
that he's in possession of the obelisk
and we know this through agender I'm
sorry through agents of shield because
this is when he began experimenting
using the obelisk on a group of Chinese
villagers one of which was the woman
that would later on become the wife of I
guess mr. Hyde and the mother of Daisy
Johnson now what also happens here is
that Daniel Whitehall somewhere along
the line after recovering all these
various artifacts including the obelisk
as well as the acree corpse is
discovered and captured by the SSR by
the strategic science reserve and this
is when we saw the first episode of
agent Carter picking up this is when we
saw her I guess meeting with and talking
to the Howling Commandos and ultimately
taking these things in a confiscation
for for the SSR now in 1946 this is when
we see the establishment of shield this
is when shield first begins to take form
now this happens this really comes out
of the the Marvel Cinematic Universe or
the Marvel film one shot agent Carter
was basically a very short film that
kind of gave us the rundown on how it
was an aging Carter had basically gotten
to the kind of things that she did and
what took place after agent Carter the
TV show came to an end and one of the
things we find is that of course her
boss at the time John Flynn is very much
misogynist and he basically continues
the trend of giving her paper work of
basically kind of I guess confining her
to remedial tasks who through remedial
jobs and so what happens is that once
Howard Stark has basically been
exonerated as we saw at the end of agent
Carter once he's basically able to step
into the role of helping to build shield
he simply informs John Flynn that Peggy
Carter will basically be co-running
shield along with him and so what this
does is bring an end to pretty much all
the significant events in the 1940s and
so what we'll do in the 1950s is we'll
find things are actually very limited in
terms of significant events a civil Jim
from the 1950s and we'll do the 1960s at
the same time and we'll see a lot of
things taking form very very fast with
that being said I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace
be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly